so if you aren't aware judeon went to
some town in arkansas which is
considered the most racist town in in
the usa and basically interviewed a
bunch of people hassan played the video
without two seconds and basically said a
bunch of stuff and so to dion hearing
what he said felt some type of way and
here are his comments that's that that's
basically hasan abby right
the reason why i want to react to this
video with you guys is because
i felt very very very very very very
very patronized watching his video and
then also
reading the comments baffled like
how are you gonna tell me i've been a
black man i've been uh i've been a black
kid and now i'm becoming a black man bro
how you gonna tell me in my 21 years of
life i don't know what
is because i i felt
bro when i tell you i've not felt like
this in my life like it's crazy bro like
basically i felt like they were telling
me how i should feel yeah get used to
that
now that you're in the art sphere you're
content creating you're going to be
around a lot of left-leaning people
you're going to be allowing a lot of
people who think they know better than
you even if they're white they're going
to tell you no as a black man this is
what you should feel has somebody's been
arts for the last 12 years i've heard it
all which is why i'm like really turned
off by these people that's how they
operate under the guise of
i know better than you and i'm here with
empathy and kindness and i'm here to
save you they will tell you how you
should feel they will gaslight you into
thinking you're supposed to be outraged
when you aren't and they'll tell you
wait that's not a thing when it's like
who made you the [ __ ] arbiters of
what's right or wrong that's been my
experience with these kind of super
progressive types just get used to it
because you're going to hear a lot more
of it
as you guys can honestly tell we're not
from here that's all right i'm from
atlanta you know i'm one of the best
rappers coming out of there and
everything like that but we've heard
rumors that this is the most town in
america but so far i'm not a lie it's
been like one of the nicest places
uh actually let's go with a booth my
booty is kind of hurting so i need more
cushioning
that's all right i'm not gonna lie
they're not really like fitting in our
narrative you're like man it's the
coolest town in america
hey can i ask you a question how long
have you lived here for 16 years 16
years like how do you like it i like it
they said that this place was like the
most town in america but like like what
have you seen here that you would like
deemed maybe
out in zeke which is probably like a 20
minute drive the leader of the ku klux
klan or whatever lives out there so this
isn't the racist hound zinc we have
people of course but you're going to
find that everywhere sure i don't know
why americans have such a twisted and
broken [ __ ] understanding of what
is which is weird i mean i know gideon
doesn't give a [ __ ] because he's like
you know he's a content creator first
like that's what i mean no i do give a
[ __ ] because you know
first i'm a black man like it doesn't
matter how many followers i have or what
influence i have first thing first i'm a
black man you know like not everybody in
the world knows who i am you know when
people just see me walk down the street
just a regular black guy so
first thing i do
i do care and then second thing i care
about my people i love my people i love
being a black man i have no shame about
it at all and i love my blackness and i
love
there's just something funny
about a black man trying to convince a
white man he loves black people
that's how bizarre this world is you
don't care about black folks like no i
love why am i just to my side to this
[ __ ] random to who
to assign hot
hassan piker's the same person who says
he cares about trans people but tells
them to shut the [ __ ] up when they have
an opinion because they don't do it
because you're just a trans person
todd's relationship with the trans
community is interesting he once lost a
trans-related debate and people in his
community were rightfully upset with
them because they felt like he made them
look bad my issue as a trans person is
the fact that you a guy that isn't super
well versed on trans ship brought on a
known transport knowing he might bring
up transphobic [ __ ] you aren't exactly a
vash of trans debates i hope
i hope
that
the rest of your life is as horrible as
it is every single day okay there you go
suck my dick i despise you i despise you
more than anything else on the planet
you are [ __ ] cancer you are just a
trans person sorry you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about see i
always tell y'all be careful of these
[ __ ] progressive people who try to
fight me off there's obviously people on
the right who hate minorities or hate
look fine but these people who've come
under the guise that wanted to help you
those are was it malcolm x
was it
was martin luther king martin luther
king and the polite racism of white
liberals
he warned about this for a long time
where people come under the guise this
has been a thing forever it's not not
new it's not brand new it's been around
since good old days just because they
lean left don't mean that they for you
or they understand you or they know
better but they'll convince you they do
and that's the same arrogant us attitude
that a lot of these guys in progressive
circles take what he's always
worried about is is you know making
[ __ ] uh
click bait stuff and and and doing
comedy or whatever it doesn't really
matter what the uh like messages overall
but that's not how this works like you
know isn't just done
the video is two minutes he's in the
video two minutes and 34 seconds and he
already judged what the entire video was
he literally just judged what the entire
video was yeah
that's what he does and he'll complain
if you clip him
it's kind of how these things work
he literally just said i was just there
to get a clickbait title and make some
shitty jokes and do comedy and stuff
like that two minutes into the video
like i mean i'm not gonna lie you could
literally see by like the intro the tone
that i had said
so it's just like why are you already
jumping to the conclusions of
a like what i went there for and then b
how are you going to like simply tell me
how i should feel about a town that hey
you just probably figured out about and
then b a town i know for a fact you
never step foot in you've never been to
harrison arkansas
you haven't talked to the locals there
you haven't talked to the minority
locals there like i did so it's like how
are you gonna sit up here and tell me
like how it really is from all places
right here bro i mean everybody's saying
that this is the most like town in
america supposedly it is but it's been
like chill like this chill i love it
this is not made up the kkk keeps
neighbors with their [ __ ] leader
really damn you they would like beat my
ass if i like showed up
no they don't i don't i don't know
i heard stories so he's a current leader
yeah and he's cool people i met him he's
pretty cool but this is the man we need
to find y'all do you think it'll be
dangerous if we go to zinc
probably not everybody just kind of
tries to stay away from them so people
don't really have information on them
their mindset is on trying to keep you
know it kind of whitewashed here yeah
you know i want more people to just get
out of the hood in general
all right boys man so right now we don't
have any leads on how we can get over to
zinc so we're trying to see if we can
find anybody that knows any people over
there so that way like we won't really
be coming unannounced and stuff like
that i'm not gonna lie that'd be like
really cool if we could get like an
interview with the leader of the kkk
isn't it crazy how like we went to the
most racist town in america but we're
like looking for the racism oh i thought
that was the confederacy just the
arkansas flag
i was like never mind we found it who
was your nose tom rob i need to talk to
him i've got some business to handle i
don't like
excuse me man do you know tom raw about
any chance no i do not you don't do you
guys know who tom rob is sir we don't
have time for this oh okay i'm sorry
this is what journalism is you have to
find the scoop by any chance you know
anybody that lives in zinc
you know trying to have a interview with
the leader of the kkk tom rob yeah good
luck
looking more and more like we just have
to go out there attention patrons at
walmart i am trying to conduct an
interview with tom robb does anybody
know tom robb by any chance raise your
hand if you might know tom robb
that's wild i'm not i ain't talking to
you matter
that's wild i'm not gonna lie that was
wild that was a lot that was why
that is kind of wild that he's doing
that like i mean he's actively trying to
put himself in a situation where he is
like physically going to be harmed
potentially you know what's so crazy you
know what's so crazy i bet you all these
people when blm was happening back in
2020 and stuff like that they were
reposting the black uh
the black square and stuff like that all
that stuff anything black lives matter
related retweeting and stuff like that
but i bet you these [ __ ] would never
leave their house go into the field
because how are you gonna stop racism
if all you're gonna do is just cancel it
behind the screen like you can't bro
you're gonna have to get down and dirty
and get in the field and stuff like that
again a lot of this activism is
performative yeah it's like i got an
opinion i'm going to be super loud about
it i'm going to tell you what it should
be in politics but as far as what they
actually do within their own communities
abroad they don't care that's why they
buy themselves mansions and live in
beverly hills away from all the [ __ ]
ills of the world they don't live in any
of these areas they don't really
interact with it they try to distance
themselves from it as much as possible
same with the fans they just be there in
the [ __ ] livestream chats just typing
away but it doesn't mean that they're
actually involved so yeah i won't take
their opinion seriously and i do think
it's dope that you know there's a
perception of a place and you're like
let me go out there to confirm for
myself not listen to what my parents
told me or what the internet told me let
me go see for myself and i think there's
something commendable about that even if
it is a little wild and crazy i think
it's dope that you want to investigate
yourself you know what i'm saying it's
kind of like you when you went to haiti
what did everyone tell you before you
went bunch of [ __ ] good or bad
not so good
and once you went what happened it's
great
same for me people tell me oh haiti is
this here i've been i had an amazing
time and we were in the middle of
uh karfuffle yeah yeah yeah
middle in the middle of a conundrum i'm
just saying that because you like big
words yeah uh
and it was even that didn't change the
perspective that i had no because i
understood why the people were mad yeah
you understand so yeah so you have to go
check for yourself you have to go see
for yourself sometimes there's some
things you need to see for yourself
before you get out here and proudly
exclaim such loud opinions without
knowing or don't be criticizing people
who do decide to go and make their own
decisions you get what i'm saying
because they're actually willing to go
there to confirm
and you want a critique
you're [ __ ] stupid it's like beth
let's go see what's going on there there
are minorities that work there that live
there let's go talk to them yeah
and these things are calling me a clown
this is the cringiest [ __ ] and stuff
like that but i bet you if you ask any
of these people they'll be like oh yeah
i'm totally against
but if i was to ask them to come out
with me to help like make a change and
stuff like that these [ __ ] would stay
right in their chairs bro they would not
[ __ ] leave their house at all they
would stay right in their [ __ ] chairs
and just watch behind the screen
how you doing
good good walk with me yes sir i grew up
with both of his sons oh you did yes
okay don't use my name you know how it
worked it worked
it worked
so so we [ __ ] stepped up there
like yo walk with me let's talk
it worked he went there open heart open
arms and people seem to be embracing for
what i can tell so hey good on him yeah
like if you call someone somebody out
in your own hometown yeah
yeah not good for business but what do
you want me to know
oh no i'm not trying to know anything
like we just like me personally
you don't think he will brother i could
tell you some story how we used to have
to cut the tails off black people when
they're born
stuff like that so do they have do they
have a lot of pool in this area that's
what we call it backwards cool you see
right now me doing this i'm gonna sell
out
man to the hill club to the people
around here he's losing this pool you
see what i'm saying yeah people's
getting educated and they're also
starting to step out for once i've been
around here like i haven't seen nothing
but nice people the only reason i come
up is you get balls oh for asking that
yeah hell yeah
no i'm not going there to change his
mind you know like he grew up believing
what he believes so they have a church
and if you read your bible he was
created by god shaping him out of clay
and breathing breath and his nostrils
yes sir that's the white man
you are considered a beast no different
than a cow a horse so they preached that
like we were yes oh oh my god
that's the thing listen
these conver these conversations are
really hard to have
you're gonna hear some [ __ ] that you're
not gonna like yeah but in order to
understand what's going on
i understand what is going on they hate
me yes fair i get you
but where it's from and how they were
indoctrinated
you have to have conversation very hard
conversation that's the thing that's
very hard i never heard about the whole
biblical thing where breath made out of
clay in the white but but but you know
people say this is crazy why would you
even waste time with these people i
personally wouldn't do it but there's a
guy who goes on joe rogan often and he
goes basically converts folks who are
part of the crew club
and basically makes it he collects their
own yeah and basically takes them away
from that and they do change for the
better and he talks about how they got
there and he takes the time i'm not
saying everybody should do the work or
everybody should want to i'm just saying
there are people who are willing don't
get in their way and don't call them
clowns if they're willing to do
something to change people to be better
folks why would you try to get in their
way you know what i'm saying so me i
would never do this but hey i'm not
going to say nothing and i do think it's
interesting to hear their perspective
because it's not stuff i would normally
hear you talk about the hill folks he's
talking about how he's losing sway over
the town because people are educated
they're going to school they don't care
about that [ __ ] so you're hearing how
like
even how a lot of these ideologies don't
have the same hold anymore than it used
to and that's the thing is that whenever
what you do is that you base yourself in
just an article
article that says harrison worst town in
america and then you just go off of that
yes you how can you blame the media for
so much but rely on what the media is
saying and for stuff like that yeah and
then you don't go out there and look it
for yourself you don't go out there and
find your information for yourself yeah
and that's what he's doing so i'm not
saying again like abba said i'm not
saying that i wouldn't necessarily do
and go out there but he's doing it and
he sees
from the people that are working there
not only the they're living there not
only the minorities but also the people
the white people that are living there
yeah what if y'all and y'all friends
come by
scoop me up and we go drive up there
together
[Music]
how fast can you get this all set up
right we got you like 30 minutes we got
you let's do it let's do it so he's
taking a bunch of local school kids who
like were willing to go with a bunch of
white kids and i'm going to go up
together with them to the
ku klux klan and they went because they
went to speak to him prior yeah no they
they went to speak to them private to
see if he would come out to set up the
meeting and he's like let's just all
just drive up together you gotta tell
your parents what you guys are doing
right yeah they're cool okay okay
all right they told their parents so
don't get mad at me mom
i'm going to the kkk headquarters right
now
mom it's bigger than black and white i
love you mom
all right mom i'm sorry i'm i'm about to
meet the grand wizard i gotta go
this is what he said i remember just the
other day man i made my dad the hearts
kid
because he's saying like are you going
to are you going to lithuania yeah
because i was supposed to go to
lithuania to perform for the troops
right like are you going and he's like
uh i'm like yeah no i'm not going but
uh on june second i'm going to prison
he's like what like you know i'm gonna
perform for the prison i'm like yeah you
can leave now you can you could leave
you thought you could you could no you
don't yeah you you can leave
the way you know exactly what the hell
you did when you said that like that
hello how you doing okay i was trying to
see if
mr robb was maybe here no oh i'm a
youtuber my name is jadeon i was just
wondering if like we could have like
maybe like a little dialogue with mr rob
if he has any free time and stuff like
that right now he's getting different
stuff together and for the uh conference
that's coming up so i heard about that
what can you ask can i ask what that
conference about uh faith and freedom i
don't know if there's any way maybe i
could come
no
especially not ah feel that paranoia
some people have i mean we aren't
anarchists all we we just came you know
as america you know got the first
amendment you know freedom of speech and
everything like that uh actually i don't
believe in that because if you have
someone who can lose their job and their
ability to support their family that
they love
where they might have been brave enough
to speak up they won't put their
children and their wife at risk so do
you feel like here the truth is spoken
i would say
as much as can be from the videos i've
seen online and stuff like that i'm sure
you've seen them you know i was
expecting to just like you know step
right foot into town and then call the
n-word but
if you even make you feel better i'll
try it for you
i don't mind i don't mind i mean do you
want me uh to help you
johnny gone get the banana
and my rifle i hear people they were
like nah the racists aren't in harrison
they're over in zinc and they were
talking about how like they like kind of
kicked you guys out of harrison no white
person for the most part moves to seek
out diversity
they'll give lip service to it and move
as far away as possible from it put up
gated communities
what that's literally what you did
hassan
your [ __ ] home in beverly hills
stupid
you kind of do
listen
you don't need to like the man and what
the [ __ ] you saying but he's absolutely
right why people will talk and cry and
say all this [ __ ] about [ __ ]
diversity the areas they move to are
predominantly exclusively white or they
will move into a place where there is
diversity and white watch the [ __ ] yeah
gentrification is a thing and it's not
white conservatives doing it okay it's
white liberals
i like his neighborhood let me do a shop
here and raise the prizes come on that
man
that's your haul come on now let's keep
it let's keep it fine but let's me
personally like i i agree to a certain
extent and stuff like that you know as
black people you know we look out for
each other you know it's like you know
you people say black power they look out
for black businesses and stuff like that
i'm not a segregationist i'm a
separationist every
white country and only white countries
are expected to become melting pots of
humanity and
that's my stance i pose white genocide
dude the funniest part is like ask this
[ __ ] like how did that happen
you know what i mean if you don't want
it to be a [ __ ] melting pot which by
the way why is that bad
no obviously but if you don't want it to
be a [ __ ] melting pot like you know
that don't colonize [ __ ] and
even then it's like well you we gotta do
that obviously like he's right about
that 100 agree it's like black folks in
america just didn't end up there
they were brought there can't be
complained about the fact that their
existence is there and they're growing
in numbers when uh the reason they got
there is because of your ancestors yeah
but you wouldn't have that reply because
you wouldn't met that guy if he wouldn't
have gone there that's right so
so now so now the thing is so now the
thing is you're commenting not on his
video but on the views of that dude but
that part wouldn't have happened if that
dude would have met them i'm not here to
change anybody's mind or nothing like i
said like that's i just want to like i
feel like the conversation should always
be had because i feel like for there to
be improvement into the future you have
to hear something different than your
own opinion i often get an assumption
made about me and they wonder if black
people did something bad to me
whitefield have done something bad to me
and i don't hate them either yeah but
it's never about that
it's a heavy certain thing to say bro
zoomers are unsalvageable dude i swear
to [ __ ] god i know that people are
going to turn around uh young gideon
fans are gonna turn around and [ __ ]
yell at me and be like he's black you're
not what the [ __ ] do you know about
over the [ __ ] but like god damn dude
just straight brain broken if you're
like oh what a civil conversation this
dude's literally a [ __ ] white
separatist man he just said it he said
it openly like he's part of the clan
unironically turns into a great example
of how
insidious but so
um so apparent and and very much a part
of people's lives because like if your
takeaway from this is like oh well look
actually they're not that at all that's
not what he said no he said that's not
what he said
that's not what
you're that's not what he's that's just
not what he said
he just said that the conversation was
going well he's not being yelled at to
having opposing pausing views but
they can talk to each other yeah his
views are [ __ ] up but they can talk
that's what a civil conversation is
doesn't defeat the fact that he's not
racist or he's racist you can have civil
conversations with people who have the
most abhorrent views that's it and you
can talk to people who have views that
are absolutely disgusting it doesn't
mean the fact that it's a conversation
and a civil one yes you started this
video black this guy's about to get hate
crime for the vine here they are just
talking kindly like if you walk away and
think that this is not the most race
people can still look at this dude and
say he's incredibly racist and they
wouldn't be wrong yeah doesn't change
the fact that they were able to talk
about it still civil something you've
proven to be incapable of by us
if your takeaway is like looking at a
guy who showed up says he's a part of
the clan and is a white separatist not a
segregationist and your takeaway is like
he can
or not your take away but like your
takeaway should be
that even a guy who's like straight up
saying like
uh you know that they're a white
separatist
can be polite to a black person to their
face okay that does not change the
reality that they're like violently and
virulently raised
well i sort of like that oh you like i
like you know this is why i'm taking
away from it
just because he didn't you're basically
saying to me
what i like this is how i personally
feel this is how i feel like bro like
this isn't like factor this is all
opinion this is how i feel what you're
saying to me
is
i don't understand basically what's
going on in this situation
that i just had this this was a 45
minute conversation that we cut down
that in this 45 minute conversation i
have no idea what was happening and
stuff like that and i need to relook
everything that's like that's basically
yeah this is what he's saying
because again in his head he knows
better than everyone
dude's like a borderline
mark the way he engages with stuff he's
convinced he knows better than everyone
even though he's not that bright when it
comes to most social issues
and he has a condescending attitude to
anybody who disagrees or doesn't share
his stake
that's who he is he cries about no i'm
getting bullied online folks keep
conquering the truth is
he just knows better than you and he can
never be wrong
so
i get why it bothers you you're a young
man you're not used to this stuff what
i'm going to say to you is that get used
to it
get very very used to it because white
liberals be like that they're the only
group i've ever seen talk to me this way
i'm not enjoying it they're the only
group i've ever had talk to me like that
so i'm just always like taking it back
sometimes but
i've already come to terms i'm like oh
that's that [ __ ] that i've been seeing
yeah so just just know
um there's that as far as your video
goes i think it's a commendable thing to
want to do that is is judeon
the most apt person to cut through
the nuances of systemic issues and towns
like this and the history of course not
but he has a huge following he's
speaking to a young audience and at
least he's bringing them towards a place
of let's talk
that's a great thing to even get these
kids interested in this stuff is already
big to get them to want to talk and to
be sit with the other side fantastic i
would argue that his audience is far
more preferable to talk to than hassan's
audience undoubtedly so any day of the
week i would take that so
props to him good video on his part um
if you guys want i'll put a link to both
videos
but yeah that's my thoughts what do you
want to say you said what you said all
right let us know